as many of you might remember in October
I had appendicitis and had surgery here
in Boston and I was out for a couple of
shows one of the things that I've been
telling you is that once I have the
total cost of my procedure I would sort
of open the books so that we could look
together and confirm once again how
absolutely and utterly insane our
healthcare system is I now have those
numbers and then ready to show them to
you and they are shocking truly so quick
reminder last Monday I told you about
how my health insurance is changing from
2019 to 2020 if I choose to stay on the
same plan right now I pay for twenty one
a month that's four hundred twenty one
dollars a month that same plan goes up
to four hundred and fifty eight dollars
a month for inferior coverage in 2020 my
out of pocket maximum goes up my co-pays
go up tons of people who are either from
other countries or have employer
subsidized insurance emailed me shocked
that this is how bad it is here in
Massachusetts where we're supposed to be
better off than lots of other places in
Massachusetts now I am ready to tell you
the full cost of my procedure now I had
looked up what is an appendectomy cost
in the United States and I found a range
that says it can go anywhere from $1,500
to a hundred and eighty thousand dollars
now presumably the high range of that is
if it's a more complex appendicitis with
a ruptured or perforated appendix where
you often have to stay in the hospital
for several days to treat the infections
that sometimes happen now to be clear I
got good care the surgeon was great
the anesthesiologist was great the
nursing staff was great really you know
I don't recommend getting an
appendicitis but it was made as least
bad as possible by really great medical
care that I received they don't control
the prices this is not about them my
appendectomy cost twenty seven thousand
four hundred ninety five dollars for the
eight or so hours that I was in the
hospital let's put the numbers up so
we'll go through this particularly
for people that Arneson listening the
anesthesiologist fee was about 1700
bucks the surgeon charged about 2500 the
visit to me at the emergency room by a
different surgeon to tell me about the
procedure was four hundred and sixty
dollars the emergency room doctor who
came over and told me they think I have
appendicitis that was 682 of course I
had to pay three hundred and sixty eight
dollars or was billed this is not what I
had to pay the radiologist charged
nearly four hundred dollars for looking
at my cat scan and telling me I have
appendicitis
I had the urgent care visit earlier in
the day where they told me we don't
think you have a cap Endocyte us that
was wrong that was 4:45 my post-op visit
and blood work and then the big charge
was the facility and all of the
different supplies the operating room
the anesthesia etc more than $20,000
there my painkiller prescription eighty
five for a total bill of twenty seven
thousand four hundred and ninety five
dollars for my as they call it
uncomplicated appendicitis so the next
question is how much do I pay I told you
I have a two thousand dollar annual
deductible for my health insurance and I
expected since my health care spending
was minimal and I didn't think I had
made any progress towards the deductible
being covered earlier in the year I
expected I would have to pay two
thousand dollars and I was right but in
fact it is more so for me my
out-of-pocket on my nearly twenty eight
thousand dollar appendectomy is my two
thousand dollar deductible a 55 dollar
Urgent Care copay from earlier that day
a fifty dollar copay for my
post-operational bloodwork a thirty
dollar a post-op visit copay a three
hundred dollar emergency room copay I
also had to pay twenty bucks out of the
85 for the painkiller prescription which
I didn't even end up taking and then of
course I also paid for my insurance in
October for 21 so my total October 2019
including my insurance premium for this
appendectomy
two thousand
876 dollars just a few interesting items
from my itemized bill there's so much
more to it but just a few things I found
notable when I arrived they said hey
listen we should just we don't know
what's going on yet but anytime people
come in we try to keep them hydrated so
we're gonna give you an IV I said sure
that was 188 dollars I I'm glad they did
it I mean it does seem like a good
practice but that nearly $200 for the
saline bag
a seed the CT scan of course they needed
to do a CT scan to determine if I have
appendicitis that was more than $2,000
billed to insurance the IV tylenol I was
given before the procedure was a hundred
and fifty three dollars and you know
they didn't leave me in the hallway they
brought me to a recovery room after the
procedure that was six hundred and
seventy eight dollars now what's
interesting about that is they said that
because they would probably only keep me
a few hours after the procedure they
didn't need to bring me upstairs to a
room now if I was brought upstairs to a
room we would be talking about thousands
more dollars because that would be
considered being admitted to the
hospital they didn't do that instead
they put me in the recovery room for
ninety minutes
that was 678 much cheaper than bringing
me up to a room so once again what's the
big picture here the nurses were great
top-notch surgeon anesthesiologist was
great everyone's bedside manner was
great they treated my girlfriend really
well even after as I was already on
valium and being wheeled in I yelled out
I hope I don't die which was not exactly
in confidence inspiring to her at the
time they treated her well they treated
me well but this is an insane system now
I want to be really clear owing $2,800
it's not going to bankrupt me right I I
always assumed that at any time because
of the insurance I have with the $2,000
deductible I might owe two to three
thousand dollars at any time if I have a
need for medical services so it's not
going to bankrupt me but that puts me in
a privileged position because we know
that half the country I believe it is
can't afford an unexpected four hundred
dollar bill what happens with a $2,800
bill it's a sickening and disgusting
system nearly 20
thousand dollars and of course the
hospital is not getting $28,000 because
my insurance will go to them and say
we're only paying this amount and the
hospital accepts it and the fact that
they know they only get part of it back
from the insurance causes them to have
higher and higher sort of MSRP booked
rates for a lot of these things it the
system is broken I don't pretend that
what I had is even close to the most
serious or expensive thing that people
would have this is relatively simple
uncomplicated thing and still look at
what we are talking about sickening
disgusting system hope this gives you
some insight particularly to our viewers
outside the US as to how all of this
works